New York City Mayor Bill DeBlasio spoke
to the Guardian on Tuesday The Guardian
is a crazy left British newspaper so it
was basically no different than a Blasio
talking to himself crazy stuff comes out
of his mouth and people with butterfly
nets make a circle because the loony bin
might be the only place left for de
Blasio and his make-believe politics how
was a lie he told the Guardian if you
could remove News Corp from the last 25
years of American history we would be
more unified country we would not be
suffering a lot of the negativity and
divisive Nisour going through right now
we went to the mainstream media for
comment on this blatant attack on the
press Stelter x' head on a cricket only
on the 5 ladies and gentlemen bill de
blasio when was the last time you gave
this towering piece of politics of
thought so he thinks America would be
better off without us what he's really
saying is he would be better off without
us but he's wrong even without America's
most watched news channel making fun of
him other progressives still shun him
he's seven feet of political
invisibility so it should be easy to
pretend to Blasio's dumb ideas don't
exist but if that were the case millions
of people would be better off you can't
beat leftism for burdening humanity and
that's why lurch hates us we point this
out while doing our best to ignore him
anyway over at CNN brian Stelter denies
the mayor's words are an attack on the
press claiming it's not about the media
at all but a media empire right I guess
if Trump didn't say it it's not a story
and if it's about Fox who cares
we get it run along Brian Anderson's
lunch is getting cold okay Dana de
Blasio is the mayor he's not the
president but I mean he wants to be the
yes yes I think this is all about he's a
term-limited lame duck this was right
around the time when in Iowa Democratic
hopefuls start going out there
yeah like basically send out a signal
and attacking leading publications is a
way to do that hmm where did you learn
that yes president Trump's been very
effective with it I don't know if it
will work for de Blasio I I assume not
but I do think that he's waiting back
some of these bigger fights like he
wants to pick a fight with uber here in
New York City yeah and that's partly
because he needs some reason some way to
get national coverage yeah
Canada's double standard the fact that
you know he's they're talking about Fox
not a big deal because you know we
everybody knows what Fox is so it's CNN
is that a serious question double
standard on the left I mean it's water
wet this is what we've seen all the time
this is their entire thing you can we
can do it but you guys can the left
loves this you know they've been
unusually silent at CNN this week they
were silent when we were attacked
although they spent all of last week
crying about Jim Acosta and the CNN Sox
chant which by the way it kind of does
okay this is what they do and it's it's
sickening but at the same time it's like
par for the course this is the number
one network for a reason nobody cares
what the Blasio thinks Rollo I was gonna
ask you a question but I can tell you're
about to talk well
why just because my Cheeta Blasio you
know everybody know he's what has always
impressed me about de Blasio is that for
all his dominance of local politics New
York mayoral politics and local politics
he has zero national appeal zero
charisma yes I mean when you compare it
to Bloomberg or Giuliani or even to Ed
Koch before that you know here's a guy
she's a giant guy dominates physically
and yet he has zero kind of appeal it
doesn't move the needle at all I don't
think there's any future in the
Democratic Party he's never talked about
I don't think any year and and I really
really has it out for Fox those he I
mean we have press Park outside I've
always had press parking I'm 47 48 years
in the business I've always had NYP
plates because I always Park right in
front of my my shop I worked at ABC 15
years NBC eight years at the talk show
at CBS 11 years and that was headed my
review he took NYP parking away from Fox
News they still have it at NBC two
blocks up
I think America Jessie have you lost any
preferred parking since the Blasio's
become there I remember de Blasio
physically had me removed from his press
conference by security asked him a
question did they pick you up no they
couldn't I'm pretty good strong so he's
very prickly he's very sensitive
he doesn't want unity in this country he
wants a monopoly they can't be content
with 90 percent control over the media
they need a hundred percent control they
can't stand criticism and they want
praise he tweeted at me and says Jesse
Watters doesn't belong in New York City
he was getting warm in a tent during New
Year's Eve and I wanted to go down there
and get warm too and I was told by his
security no you're not allowed to be
ashamed waited at you right now begin to
like this mayor get out of my tank my
tan Jesse well that's intolerant if you
can't allow you know Jesse to get warm
we let this thing go by without talking
about the obvious degradation of this
city yeah no it's true I've lived here
but seven years eight years and in the
last view you can really see a decline
every day you see it more yeah because
it's an uber but nobody know the thing
is he'll all do it's because auction on
every block no rob was because nobody
votes in New York because they assume
one's gonna win so he would thirty
twenty percent of the people vote I was
shocked by that the other morning when I
was walking there's so many homeless
people and it it weeks in New York City
was cleaner three years ago they serve
to be treated better than that the ante
percent it's all Geraldo's fault because
of the deinstitutionalization blaming
you her although I'm kidding there all
right that's right no not with that
Democrat policy dopey you get
run as an independent run is an
independent John James by the way should
campaign as a Democrat in Michigan yeah
even though he's a Republican he should
go too
he should be in Detroit should be in
Flint did you get what I want why don't
you run as an independent
uh time is passed I was having this is
I'm gonna eat poutine now you know how
to talk about that later are there great
food they're yelling at me rice and
beans margaritas hungry